JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Bien a todas las partes presentes en la audiencia virtual. Tenga muy buenos días. Vamos a
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: instalar la presunta audiencia previo verificación de las partes, si es que están todas las partes. Señora Secretaria, abogada.
secretaria: Informa por secretaría que las partes han sido legalmente notificadas, encontrándose en sala.
secretaria: acusación particular fabio Corpus Ramírez, sin su abogado
secretaria: presente, el acusado Jaime Edmundo, palacios Salas, asistido de su abogada doctora Gabriela Condori de Set depp y ausente el Ministerio público es en cuanto a su informe.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Muy bien si tiene presente y en mérito el informe evacuado, También debemos complementar
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: dicho informe en el sentido de que el abogado del doctor Carlos Quisvelt Mendieta ha solicitado suspensión de esta audiencia refiriendo que estaría de viaje el día de hoy
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: y a tal efecto apuntado un pasaje electrónico, un ticket en el cual se evidencia que estaría viajando a
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: la ciudad de Cochabamba
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: En tal sentido, ante la ausencia tanto del Ministerio Público y el abogado de la parte
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: que digan que víctima tiene la palabra
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Septed para que pueda pronunciarse al respecto.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: copiar la actualidad, donde quien dirigía.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: no la escuchamos doctora, la se le escucha muy lejana, No, absolutamente, por lo menos. Yo no la escucho.
Sepdep: Buen día. Señor magistrado, señor magistrado, vamos a estar a lo que su autoridad dispongan.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Muy bien
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: viene en mérida lo informado por secretaría y cuanto se ha podido señalar en esta audiencia ante la ausencia del representante del Ministerio Público y la Defensa y el señor abogado de la parte y querellante, vamos a disponer la suspensión de esta audiencia, señora Secretaria, abogada, la Agenda. Por favor.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: vamos a señalar una nueva fecha.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Ohh, No, No.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: bien para el día
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: para el día miércoles, 3 de diciembre a horas, 9 de la mañana. En punto.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Reitero, para el día miércoles, 3 de diciembre, a horas
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: 9 de la mañana. En punto.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Con este señalamiento, todas las partes presentes quedan notificadas. Así mismo, por Secretario, no tiene que ser a un señor fiscal asignado el caso de la Homs, con lo que ha concluido la presunta audiencia.
Sepdep: Una palabra, señor magistrado y doctora. Gracias, señor magistrado. Señor magistrado. Voy a solicitar a las autoridades en este nuevo oficio para Defensa pública, siendo que la presente audiencia sea
Sepdep: asistido dando cumplimiento al oficio. Asimismo, señor magistrado, darle a conocer que la suscrita culmina sus funciones en defensa pública, el 28 de noviembre. En ese sentido, por favor, señor Magistrado, Solicitar, se emita nuevo oficio.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Ajá
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: bien, de acuerdo a lo señalado por defensa pública, por la señora abogada nuevamente oficiosa defensa pública, para que pueda contar con defensa técnica. El acusado
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: en tal sentido Ha concluido la presente audiencia, tengan ustedes buenos días, hasta luego a todos.
Sepdep: Hasta luego. Señora.
JUEZ ROLANDO MAYTA: Aplausos.